oft liegt das gute in der nähe verbirgt
sich im kleinen wie vielleicht in dieser
käserei im aargauischen gut wie hier
sucht er nach neuen geschmacks
empfindungen der fuß guard dominik
flammer besucht käser bergmeier um
inspirationen für seine publikationen zu
erhalten
das sind einfach die in costa rica wo
ich nach wie vor an um vor allem reger
wo vor einer halbwertszeit strukturen
die vergessen ganz viele vergessen filme
vergesse bio
ich vergesse kunstwerken und seyhan
kindheit vergleich in dieser woche ihren
er findet sie beim käse sofern diese
eigenständig und vielfältig ist wie oft
bei lokalen spezialisten
auch der zweite zwischen hals auf der
entdeckungstour gilt einen regionalen
produzenten in einer ehemaligen fabrik
im zürcherischen wetzikon hat sich vor
knapp drei jahren ein experte für
fleisch und fisch eingerichtet in dem er
seine produkte räuchert belebt er eine
traditionelle form nahrungsmittel
haltbar zu machen
das besondere an patrick marxer er nutzt
das ganze tier und er nutzt alte tiere
was andernorts im abfall landet
verarbeitet der lebensmittel veredler zu
produkten mit markantem geschmack
geschmack der durch die standardisierung
in der fleischindustrie weitgehend
verloren gegangen sei
und zwar zu recht sauer schmeckt
intensiv wenn ich formularen jedes
stuttgart und am feld in den stick
schmack bitte darum bringt in hohenau
und das würde ich auch mal wieder nichts
mit dem ersten kuss war es apropos
gemüse patrick marx r reichert auch
zwiebeln und mais
der leichte holzofen geschmack werte das
gemüse auf aus einfacher nahrung eine
spezialität machen
nichts neues in der ernährungs
geschichte wo die post erst mal um 1980
haben in paris auf den nächsten tag
müssen um das steuer domhof stelle
da hat man als in reihe von fischteichen
armee nahe xi'an absolute delikatesse im
rennen gemerkt hässliche bis 21 und
genauso gut war einfach merken ja aber
als kur fleisch ich habe ne psp von
chicken wing aus dem papier besser
juni 2 46 franken fünf und sieben stück
frittierte über hunger aber eigentlich
nur noch fritteuse schmecken
regionale produkte für den konsumenten
auch die bauern der vereinigung
hochstamm seetal im kanton luzern
besannen sich auf das eigene terror
sie haben dominik flammer beauftragt
ihre produkte zu bewerten
nicht alles überzeugt den 48 jährigen
der auch als selbständiger berater
auftritt dominik flammer hält nichts vom
geschmuggelter fachsprache
in einfachen worten will er mit menschen
auf den geschmack des geschmacks bringen